i'm deep inside an ancient pyramid on
the trail of a mysterious maya dynasty
called the snake kings
i'm so far into the heart of the pyramid
my radio doesn't work
within these twisting tunnels
it's impossible to know just how deep i
am
but if my team can scan it we'll find
out for the first time whether it still
holds undiscovered depths for sandra and
francisco to explore
so humid in here
and muggy i can barely breathe
[Music]
eventually
the tunnel ends
feels like i'm inside the center of a
mountain
and yet here are these crypts
somebody's life
was lived
and then this place
was built to honor their life after they
died
wow
this wasn't meant for the living this is
a chamber for the dead
feels like we shouldn't be here
well come on guys let's get out of here
hey you made it
it was just
like nothing i've ever seen before
you know like a spiral staircase
descending all the way to the bottom
what an experience
inside my team are already at work
scanning the tunnel system
a series of revolving lasers fire
millions of beams of light every second
reaching every last square inch of the
tunnel
later with the scan complete
i show francisco and sandra the results
you ready for this this is the front
yes
basically it's an x-ray the whole thing
yeah this is really exciting for us
the new scans reveal a massive surprise
looks like we're 2-3 meters above
bedrock
typically the first king gets buried in
the bedrock and then whoever comes after
gets buried in the building above it and
so if this is not in bedrock it means
there's another building below it
the new data that we just collected
shows that sandra and francisco still
have further to go to investigate the
origins of this mysterious city
[Music]
you